welcome to the discussion about
science and society here at
the balance 1 victory my name is
fit again man and i am a journalist and
among other things i listen to the talking
science science podcast from the
berlin university alliance and the rbb
and there is the idea that we always  invite two
scientists from
different disciplines
who talk about more or less one big
topic to simply show how
interdisciplinary research and
research as a whole and how
knowledge exchange can work. for
example, we had torsten
and jörg niewohner on the topic of climate change and the
pandemic and we want to be there  always
work out what and how
research is currently being carried out and how we citizens
can also be involved
in science and the exchange
with science in order
to master the challenges of the future
we definitely need this
exchange of knowledge questions from society
come and come from science that
opens up and is transparent and
ready for a
knowledge exchange this is what this discussion is supposed to be about today, this panel organized the objective two of the berlin university alliance for string knowledge exchange i.e. promoting the exchange of knowledge
there should be new methods  and
formats for the exchange of knowledge are tested and
discussed, so it's about an
exchange between
scientists, an exchange with artists and
citizens, students, but also
about the exchange and support
of politics for science
and all of that should be a topic today with
very very interesting panelists
apologies sabine art
buga spokeswoman and
harro call presidents until the end of the year she has
just announced her resignation
welcome nice that you
are here next to esma the psychiatrist
stress researcher eurobahn is chief physician of the
fliedner clinic berl  in and head of the
research area effect of this disturbance at
the charité in berlin you are also
project manager of a project funded by the eu
that stands for new
forms of scientific communication of
knowledge transfer and for the
inclusion of society with their
knowledge only emotional city about it
we want to be even longer  speak
welcome nice that you
are here then katja neuroscientist
and foundation manager
executive board member of the schering
foundation
you combine art and science and
see it as an instrument for promoting
science you have
developed interesting formats that
we
want to talk about in more detail in a moment nice to have you here  are
and all future issues from the free
university berlin
that is located in the
educational sciences and in education
for sustainable development at the f you
are managing director of future
farmer that is a community a
gem  non-profit educational project ifa 2009
10 was a spin-off from the fa there
are educators designers and
futurologists together and they are
now active nationwide and we also
want to talk about it in
detail right away what
kind of knowledge transfer it is a warm
welcome woman with
exactly woman and me  just
mentioned it briefly you have just announced your
resignation
but you have also
made it clear that you
want to use it to communicate that there is a
decoupling of
science and politics what
ultimately made you
decide to resign
yes so today we have one  completely
different topic, nevertheless, i don't want to back down
, in berlin,
shortly before the end of the legislature, another
law was passed by the house of representatives,
which was a good intention with very
bad craftsmanship,
so that now when you see the implications of
these decisions, it's just as
big  a revolution is like a bachelor's
master's reform and on the one hand it is
justified that many young female
scientists would also
like to have prospects in science earlier,
but it would
actually mean for the German system
that the structures in the
university now really have to be completely and
gradually rebuilt we  are
there and we also know as
university management and many
scientific institutions that we have to
do this but unfortunately that doesn't work in a
quick-fix procedure it doesn't work without money
and it doesn't work when in august
for the first time these
thoughts are also discussed politically with this sharpness
on the 29th is decided  and switched to 25 19
armed then that's
ultimately one not there was
no communication and in that respect
I say that was the decoupling of a
political decision that
seismographically recorded what
many voters wanted without
actually ensuring that the
d  he has to implement that and i mean
in general the colleagues who work as
scientists in the
universities
also had the opportunity to discuss
how, when, what do we need
for this and does it make a difference if berlin
spearheads the movement but
at the same time does that  built up i take
the excellent situation as a
research location again towards the
south loses certain
things near berlin just can’t do anymore
that was my point and at some point
you have to ask yourself he also look in the
mirror am i available for that
i may be too old
no longer creative or whatever
in any case
i don't like ripping my ass over
what has built up with my hands
with many people and that's why
i took this step i took this
step they leave the field to the
young committed colleagues who have a
lot of wind  have
there will be a replacement
so my point is  t it is a
project of a decade it requires a
consensus-oriented agreement because a university is not an industrial company how one
wanted to do it and it can if
one knows the experience from the
seventies and especially after the
reunification in the new federal states i
know  from the bottom up, then
education minister, you really have to see in
which steps with which resources
and when, and then there needs to be a
negotiation of what that should look like
and a development of criteria under
which conditions you can do something,
so that’s just a  major project
what and where the ball belongs in the
field of politics which also has an
obligation after
consultation to actually decide and
not to
learn and communicate such a hasty shot
maybe very briefly passed on because it is
also about the transfer of knowledge
politics also plays a major
role  the support of politics
vasari what experience do you have for this
so you would also speak of a
decoupling of science and politics
there well at least
this example shows exactly what we have here in
berlin that
is one that science and politics
obviously work on others via other agents
and are informed and
[music]
just as well as art that he just says
he presents us all with great
difficulties and you get the impression
that
our reality, which we have at
universities and in science
, is simply not known and is
not seen and  that's why
and since we're
also talking about transdisciplinarity today,
namely that we do science
politics informs people
informs the various understands
the various groups of actors in
society informed
i wonder we don't
actually have to worry about the fact
that there is a bidirectional
exchange  al  so we also do research for
politics but of course we also
need politics for research and for
science but i think that
usually works
pretty well but not really here
and you made a statement with
it exactly we
maybe don't want to go any further now  everywhere exactly in
our internal, so to speak, or talk about
the problem but i think the
ag said exactly how you say it
is important to simply discuss the
role of politics there
also want to go into more
detail now i would  also like
to start with you, woman art, i.e. how and
with which forms the transfer of knowledge can
work
, i.e. also how you can get
the translation of knowledge in and
for society and also maybe
with society and which
formats are a good idea for this
maybe you can believe  also directly
the hus labor there address the
Wunderkammer humboldt labo  r you
also brought pictures with you that you are
like what is the idea behind the
humboldt laboratory how is knowledge
conveyed in what form so
we are welcome to talk about this example
because there are many, many different ones in the portfolio of
the berlin university alliance
projects and the testing
of different ways here the way has been
chosen to present the results from
science via an exhibition
called against nature
and what you see here is the entrance
sculpture, if you will, which communicates the work
of several excellence clusters in berlin
it is a
programmed
swarm of fish that ultimately swarms intelligence
and
points out what research is being done in
the excellence cluster neurocure
science of intelligence
and that it actually works in such an
exhibition as an
active with the help of the excellence cluster needed a welcoming culture for the chamber of wonders
ters mathematics who
programmed it
so that now the one who
speaks to the viewers and ultimately
includes oneself as a being that
reacts in a swarm and
also communicates with them, i.e. it is
loud or quiet depending on how they
behave,
whether too quickly  or too despondent if you
are the the fish that from reports from the
grevener and easily sets a new direction
and the swarm then disappears
too if if if if you
approach it too brutally so our
on and on I do
n't want to close that now
it shows that the translation of the
diverse results from these
two clusters is a new
form of science because
the creation of something like this is actually
not the
original task of the top
research clusters, but this level of
communication is a path that
we want to take because the
valais  thesis is fascinated so
that you then also deal more with the
content and in
combination with the Wunderkammer element
in a large room behind it
,
which is geared towards the tradition of Berlin science, the Berlin Palace
, as a
symbol of science in Berlin in the
18th 19th century, actually had the
collection of oddities and
scientific objects and that in
one  modern form from the
scientific collections of the
humboldt university and others is,
so to speak, the potpourri of what you can then open up
in an
oversupply as I said a chamber of wonders
the participation of viewers is possible
because there are many formats with the
with with other elements
to deal with this exhibition, which
in turn was developed by many with many
scientists in berlin
because the exhibition is named after the natural
and
connects the crisis of nature with the crisis of
democracy and opportunities for exchange are linked to
the
program lines that are now
Open classrooms will start in the autumn, or
the feedback will be very specific on what
you see there, which means that
questions from the viewers
will also
be included. They were included in the
creation of the exhibition
and are responsible for the
further development of such an
exhibition  now the processes to
collect the feedback so
to deepen at certain points
and to develop a next exhibition
together with the
audience is always
the question how do you
really come to a co-production of
other content diddy diddy deal
with it
bring one with you and in what form
can it then be professionalized that
you are again able to show that there are
in fact other exciting
formats from the castle that we can
maybe talk about right away but i
think this is a very nice
new thing for women to do  so how sat  is a
neuroscientist and
executive director of the schering
foundation. before that, as a
neuroscientist,
you co-initiated the portal das gehirn punkt info at the non-profit
hertie foundation and you also worked as a co-author of the
children’s non-fiction book, you think about the
brain and i think it’s
important because you’re both
science also right
natural sciences medicine
in your portfolio, so to speak, but
also art now you are
responsible for two funding areas at the schering
stiftung namely for science
and art with which formats do you try
to combine these two topics
science and art as well as the
community the schering stiftung
promotes life sciences, art and
educational projects and i think, unlike
the work i did at the hertie
foundation, where it was about
establishing science communication that works on an equal footing
, where the fears of
v
we at the schering stiftung are now more
interested in the
exchange between art and science and
see this transdisciplinary approach
not only as a translation of
scientific content into
society but also
as a transformation  a bit like
what woman art already said for
this chamber of wonders that we say
yes with the arts we have the other
form of visual language so there is not
just text and diagrams and numbers
but we have pictures and artifacts
so much like a game that is pretty much
you can  there's a lot you can experience, we
go into art spaces with it, so we're
not in the universities,
we have exhibition rooms at the foundation,
where we also have exhibitions twice a year
, and it's important that the
artists deal with the
life sciences and
record them  also
from many below
taking everything from different currents and then
transforming it, a new work is created
so that sometimes it can also be that
the scientists are no longer satisfied at all
, that they do
n't find themselves in what is being created, but that's the
only way it works, there was also
friction and an examination of the
topic and  for
me, that is a very powerful tool for
promoting science because the
scientists who then deal with
the artist also get further
with science
or in their scientific
research, in my opinion, because they
get other questions or what they
believe  you so there are very
different approaches on the one hand
it can be something like
the view is getting a bit bigger
so the scientists
mainly look at the data artists also
look at the artefacts and the
noise so continue to look and
take the new results with you
on it sometimes  l are there also
exhibitions or pictures like
that that lead to the fact that you might not show the
results that you had in an
xy diagram but in a
color briskly and thereby
also recognize
completely different connections that created different
questions
there are certainly a few more  more
points where we come to talk about it
here maybe not so much about it
that is our most recent exhibition
that we had running until september
that is
the woman winterling who exhibited template
and that the work was created in
cooperation with simone schürrle who
is  nano engineer at the eth and
the power to become a nano carrier, that means she
develops small mini robots,
i.e. robots, they are
biologically produced
bacteria, so to speak, which ideally
can bring active substances into cancer tissue, for example, and the artist was there
in the laboratory and saw it for herself  looked at and
the two have very strong d  he had the topic of
borders so how do i get over
borders what kind of borders do i have
how do i see it and
this work that you see here was created you
really go into this immersive space
we had body temperature in
our exhibition room and you are up
eye level with this small bacterium
with this nanocare that's the green
thing you see there and that the tissue
is there the tissue and it's the tissue sections
these films were created from
the microscopic images so it's
not just a 1 1 image but
also a transformation  found in the
city and we in what form did
this work come about so
they met, did they talk to each other
how was the exchange i think it’s
always different the two of them
knew each other before they met
on matif one time  got to
know there are also art science
exchange formats and have always found each other
quite sp  annend and thought we would
do something together at some point and
when the opportunity came that we
offered them they
tried to work together and then it
is usually the case that at the beginning
it is important to exchange [music] in these
that the two
brings people together and that they discuss
and talk about it, get to know each other, ask
questions and for the scientists
it is also incredibly fruitful
to hear these questions because you then
get a different perspective
and new perspectives and can adapt to
them and it is at the beginning
always very, very intensively and then there is
actually a form where
the artist
withdraws a bit and
does their work then this transformation
takes place and then of course again
in the exhibition structure what woman
art said is
important again  is how do I put that down so
how curated that how press  I use that from
which pictures so that
someone else can understand it and how
can I understand that and can I
perhaps misunderstand it too and then
the mirror comes back and the
scientists in the look at it
discuss it and make a few more
adjustments in case  something
scientific because it comes across wrong
and then we have
new narratives about
our work, which is always very important for our outfits,
so that means you can
refer to it, yes, you don't understand what i
'm doing, then just look,
that's the picture  exactly because, for example, the
artists said oh the nano
carriers add that, they have such small backpacks,
such small rucksacks and so far so the
picture that the scientists have
now taken with them for themselves
and that somehow explains it quite well,
they have theirs  medication in the backpack
and then carry it to the tissue so we
can, anja  about the reception
that would have interested me again
is that Mr. area exactly is it going to be the next
exhibition brought along
maybe the next slide again
that is an older work by pina
yoldas she
asked herself what would have happened
if there had been plastic in the primordial soup
and then somehow looked at
all the colors how do
the feathers of the birds develop even older than
the largest building is already there when
you melt colorful plastic and together
with the previous days brown ones so probably insofar as
we exactly how did it
imagine it was very colorful  as
you can see from the organs that
she had developed,
which organs would actually have to
develop so that i
can do something with this plastic and
there it is just like that you learn something
about evolution, also about primordial soup, how
what is created, how you adapt
quite a lot of biological
approaches and so
you get along with it  that our seas are totally
littered with plastic
and otherwise you
always gave the exhibitions this index finger yes also
avoid this plastic and so and here it is brought
across again in a very playful
way so that you also get
intensively involved in finding other access
and  is also a bit more open and
not this but I’m not
really allowed to do anything anymore but deal
with it a little easier
and then also find a solution for
what you
might be doing with it
because then you can’t get
out of our  the current ursuppe is no longer
just from poland so exactly many thanks
first so far so as i said about the
reception for all those who can
also
speak to that correctly we can talk again in a moment i would now like
to go to
the future
plan victories  says a non-profit
educational project eve it is a
spin-off from the free university
from the institut futur and the idea behind it
is that students should be enabled to
see themselves as visionaries and designers of
a new era and
they provide teachers and school
classes with free teaching and learning material in
order to embark on such
an inspiration and search for the future
and  to enter into a bit of new
ways of thinking so for the
future
they are also ambassadors for futures
ligety of unesco and
maybe you can
explain a little bit how this year
these new inspirations
how they convey them to the
teachers but of course also
directly  to the students
and exactly the picture also reminds me of
what I'll come
to again in a moment we can leave that exactly
I was allowed to study future research
in Berlin and
at a certain point I had to write my master's thesis.
Before that I was in business in
innovations  - and special area active
and have  then noticed okay we
talk a lot will future innovation with
adults but at school
we hardly ever talk about
future trends, also critically
deal with visions of change
and, above all, what
the school is about to do
very acutely with you  to
deal with change in the world of work and that's why
i actually dedicated my master's
thesis to the topic of how to make this a field of
teaching and action at schools in the future
and 2018 was exactly the
science year the world of work of the future so it was quite
appropriate and we simply
applied and then won for  the
concept exactly you have this bullen
startup scholarship that's exactly what we
got afterwards we really got
a year from the fu berlin ist
Gründerstipendium were there the
exotic ones because it was actually more
normal for you to found a GmbH and not
something non-profit it was  an
exciting way though  exactly the idea the
future it's about the concept that
we developed it's aimed
at 13 to 17 year
olds who are supposed to go on a journey into the future so
that means there are various
teaching modules that we have
developed and also because of this inter-
transdisciplinary we are designers
futurologists pedagogues also bringing the
three worlds together was very
exciting and the students the path
is like that, so to speak. they
first deal with trends, i.e. what is currently
changing in 3d printing, autonomous driving,
but also in social movements, they
discuss a lot about it, so we
friends rather like that  a certain
a certain basic support be
curious stay open
systemic thinking and in the course of this
journey what eight modules are you will
eventually come to the point of developing a vision of
a desirable world and
from there we will go
backwards, so to speak, so we ask you in which
world  do you want to live in the year 2070 for
example
or 2035 and then of course you say
very abstract things,
a world in which everyone has
oxygen, for example, as well as here
and then the question is how
do we get there, how can I,
as a young person, somehow
manage to get there  come and
then we will let them develop missions for the
future so in the sense of
maybe an organization needs
a job description that
produces oxygen artificially and that is then exactly often such
a scientific world or field of
innovation where
research is being done on it maybe also
and yes try the students  very
tangible by making the topics trends
innovations accessible and building
a bridge from your own
life so now here for example the
organic farmer there was the idea in the
big cities are all dirty and according to
you can hardly see green why is there no
organization where then  for example
urban planners or biologists inside
working on kr  put such little babbels in the
euungen and in there you can
explore the flora and fauna and breathe deeply again
and at the end think about
what kind of training or what
kind of study can then also help me to
get there, so
this idea from  starting a career
also this this distinction between
academics and science and studies
and then craft and knowledge from experience
that we bring it back on an
equal footing because we are
talking art and science should come
together then we also have
to promote this craft again
and also make people want to do it  that's
a bit of an idea yes
super cool things come out of it because the kids are
my business the adults have to because we
have an imagination that is
still super dreamy they know
no limits
we have also set the rules
like there is no right and no  wrong
is very important to us such a discourse space
a  to create and say animal linguist
idea from a schoolgirl we
have to orientate ourselves more towards animals in the animation area
who are in the right room
and see what can they maybe
learn language from me
so there are always super great impulses
for science and innovation inside
and that was what just reminded me of your
idea to say 3d organ druckerei
if we ever
move to mars we need new
organs to help us there propeller
shoes or whatever
that we have here the idea and yes i
have it worked  let's not just
watch so our very first idea in
2018 was the camera on the oxygen
producer and i think that was a
month after he announced before nasa profit
that they want to produce artificial oxygen in space with their own
so it's very close to me and organ
pressure on the standard is
even being researched at the tu in halo
climate farmerin that the idea for
example permaculture and
to bring together traditional farmers for educational work i
think one or two more should come
in pictures of togo i only testify that's exactly
what it's really about because even
as a future researcher i can only say
there is no knowledge of the future so
we say we  are in the
knowledge society but there is
n't we can but
that's now find interesting
people for example and also the
younger they are the more idea
of visionary ideas they maybe
have but often you ask how do yo
imagine the future is then
aid  there are pictures like from star
trek or star wars or something like
that actually pictures that already exist
it's not that easy to come up with
something completely new probably
that's exactly the problem that we
often orientate ourselves on the pictures because there are
also art and  media are also very important
that are set beforehand and
I think neurowiss  society can
perhaps also confirm that
such images also have a passion and
we then consciously or
unconsciously align our actions accordingly and that is why
we just want to encourage the development of
independent images,
also a counter-construction, for example to
this strong ratti by elon musk at the
moment  who tells him about hiking to
mars
that's just driven by silicon valley
but is it also the
future negative what we
want to pursue here i don't know so there are also
things to show the schoolgirls with
imagination we can also find our own
way into the future  design
is very important
to
you, thank you very much, first of all, up to this point, the last one in the bunch is still setting master
adli,
just announced that you are also
a
co-founder of the interdisciplinary forum for
new Romance studies at the Charité for
mental health in the city, where you
work with
neuroscientists  inside and
urban researchers inside u  nd architects
together to perhaps develop a healthy city
and you are
project manager of a project funded by the eu
that has just tested new forms of
scientific
communication
july motion city as or we
are still here with the picture
maybe you can tell us
something more about it  to the interdisciplinary forum new
organist ick yes, that the idea
arose a few years ago
from the observation that people
who live in cities and grew up in cities
have a higher risk of developing
mental illnesses. it
's all about stress-related
illnesses such as  depression and
and then we asked ourselves how can
that actually be because the health care in the city is
actually
so much better than in rural
areas you can find
free psychotherapy much faster, for
example if we live in berlin
if we have 50 kilometers
actually looking from the city limits c  more
intuitively and then we
[music
] we joined forces
researchers from different berlin
universities
ht charité later colleagues also came
along and
worked together on an interdisciplinary basis because we
said we can answer this question what
actually does what is important to us in the
city  the kidneys, or rather the
brain, only answer if we are
different i.e. if instead of researching we bring
the discipline together with health research
and neurosciences and other
disciplines that is the only
way to answer this question
and that is why we founded this
interdisciplinary forum europe
together then also with
non-scientific
actors
who then form a bridge, so to speak
, to applied urban planning, for
example, and/or
representatives of various groups
who live together as citizens in the
city and then started
to answer this
question d  a that means in the end we
need a common language we
have to bring our totally different
methods together and that
is what is at the center of this interdisciplinary
forum with whom is
it particularly difficult
to find a common language than quotes, for
example with the
architects  or i
can't repair it at all it's really hard
to say there isn't such a
diametrically extremely distant
discipline i just noticed and i noticed
it all i've noticed
that's for example if we even
talk about the term stress  speaking
something totally generic
, the philosophers have completely different
ideas and architecture also
has a completely different idea than us
doctors, so these thieves, this question
what is stressed, so
stress somehow has such a negative
connotation for most people, so when
I talk about stress instead of mean  I
as a psychiatrist now not at all  s
necessarily bad or switzerland lets
you also because it keeps us alive
because it is also vital for survival that
we are able to feel stress
those of our ancestors who
did not feel stress when they were
faced with a risk or
danger either  our
ancestors have become so stress
actually sleep and are from the while
eaten exactly exactly and that first of
all, so to speak, to establish such a value-free concept of stress
is very important
so that you can start a
research search together for factors
influencing stress but that at
the point  where you still number
wrong at what point does the
stress really become a problem
and a medical problem when
it becomes chronic so if when
we talk about permanent stress that we can
not escape
at least when will if
we worry about this stress
to be able to oppose nothing then can
troops  become problematic and then it
can also make you ill so
let's
talk about this next project again joel
citi citi motion citizen science
laboratory think we'll
click again we'll see that the long corner that's currently being developed in the full extent fellow citizens
together
exactly exactly if we click on it again
then you can see the whole thing exactly
the idea is the idea is to develop an
emotional city map of berlin first of
all a kind of
emotional heat map
the whole thing is based on a
citizen science approach, i.e. on a
citizen  scientific approach
citizens of
berlin will do research
by equipping themselves with an app
that we are currently
producing together and move through
the city and indicate in
their everyday life at certain random
times how they are
feeling on an emotional scale, so to speak
are classify plus except
some more information about the social
context so am I alone or with
others
am I looking at a green area
or not and such questions
are asked I also
have to answer promo takes 1-2 minutes per
survey and so it
develops like this  our
idea is also an emotional city map of
our city, which then allows us to
better understand what
influencing factors there are, e.g. urban planning
or social
factors influencing what people feel in their city life and
the whole thing follows the idea of
ic mental health strategy for our c
ties  achievable then
our cities will grow as they indicate the
predictions of
the united nations
will soon live two thirds of humanity
emerge that it is predicted for the year 2050
now we are
just over 50 percent if that is so if that is
true if that if organization so
rapidly ahead  goes and if it is
also true that people in
s  if cities live, for example, have a twice
as high risk of schizophrenia
compared to countries with a finally living
population, then it is high
time to come up with such a
heartfelt strategy and
i see and am convinced that
this can only be achieved with such an interdisciplinary and
transdisciplinary
approach  i assume that you go in there with an
assumption so what
do you think what will come out of it
so at which points is a city
just particularly problematic and
full of stress for the residents inside i.e.
[music]
probably everywhere where stress
arises the the  you can't help but
know that he's part of it now
or doesn't listen because the
train ride is too full for me this
range is over too that's not
constant stress and if i can't stand it any
longer he gets out early so
that's stress  the nerve that
hasn't made you ill yet,
for example, it's the dense stress the
spatial confinement of
the de  r we can't avoid it at all
we just these days were
figures from the Federal Statistical Office
according to which showed that other
relevant part of the federal population also
lives in cramped conditions I
think about ten percent of
German citizens live in too small apartments
with too small apartments above
all  are children affected above
all are single parents affected
above all are city dwellers
affected so if there is a if you
don’t have no more privacy if
you don’t have any territory also that
you can withdraw from the
hustle and bustle of the city again
if there is none  There is a door that I can
also close behind me effectively
, then something like
dense stress arises and then there is the
other
major form of stress that we
have more frequently and that is social
isolation, for example
loneliness is part of it right now in the pandemic  is
also increasingly on this topic
attention has been paid
and rightly so because we see not only from our own
studies but also from studies from
all parts of the world that
loneliness
has increased due to the
pandemic, an extremely taboo topic
which has not been easy to
discuss with those affected and so
these are  isolation stress and
dense stress these are the two forms of
social stress that probably have health relevance in the city
yes very exciting it is
also a very
interdisciplinary project so with
many
live so the balance is there you are
exactly the humboldt-uni charité
but you  we also have a partner the
futur ii around there you can also try out this app,
exactly we that
the futur ii around is our very important
partner who, so to speak
, provides the connection to the population
to the audience to
the in to the citizens  creates care
and also for the communication of our
results and also this plan  ens makes
a crucial contribution are also very
happy about this connection, which
works really well i must say
and we are now also
working on the idea of how the resul
can then also be visualized in an
exhibit, so somehow keywo
d art and repre
entation of  science in the for the people
the rbb is also involved as
a media partner us media media
partner into the population
and that is, so to speak, a
we are trying
to establish this citizen scientific idea there is
a cornucopia of great examples of
interdisciplinary and transdisciplinary
research around  that radiates into science
into society
woman art we now have more than line
university alone is also again
very clearly the subject of
why this association is
particularly well suited to promoting exactly this exchange
so even in this
example we have somehow very vividly also
sat  before it
is quite trivial it is the use of
a very, very dense research area
with a variety of
people who are interested in the
most diverse things so that you can find
someone for almost every topic
and also a lot of interests
to experiment anew and it is  Not only are
the airlines particularly suitable, but the
content of this application is that the new
major challenge in research
in Berlin should be examined by
entering into a fruitful
discourse with the population so
that the problems that are seen there
are included in the
formulation of the research question  for
now a future that's why we
've put it on our agenda and
the success of the airlines will also
depend on whether it actually
works and whether what we set out here as a
thesis in berlin
really leads to results it's
a bit back  the tradition at the
moment in the area in our
spi  to subject research from oneself
to the effort of transforming
one's own again, so again in a
completely different way also to tilt the stage and take it
with oneself is for those
who could bring something in the
application that really appeals to them that they really find it
good or  how is the
reconciliation and
the lions also want to connect this question
with now the exploration of
new topics that are to be researched in Berlin in the future
, such as
social cohesion,
social crisis or now
especially triggered again from the
pandemic global holds so  we are not
on an island and how do we
actually have to draw a conclusion from what we have experienced and
observed, for example, in
recent years,
and also ask how affected
we are and determine how,
for example, the
project just described was the case
with such a topic  put on differently
not purely from a medical  chen
research but in interaction a
bit similar to how it
appeared in the picture right now
I would be interested in how you
described the formats, so to speak, which will also have the exhibition
podcast you also have where
artists and
scientists exchange ideas like they do  so feedback
is also coming questions from
viewers from citizens from
other interested scientists
maybe also a bit the question
to whom is your offer
aimed directly right there i have
two in my head now on the one hand
we are of course going to the rooms of  art and
are more open to an audience what
are from education in conversations
more the educated bourgeoisie with
our offer but of course we do
n’t go into scientific rooms have
other audience
try to make it more
accessible to create other accesses and these
feedbacks that happen in conversation
so  we have  en also always
event formats in which we
invite scientists who then also
talk to the citizens
and exchange ideas so there happens
on this level a salon in a
salon we have in the comic opera, for
example, there are two different people talking
who know everything about
different disciplines
scientists on a topic
or the wunderkammer of the opera neukölln
where we really
experience and participate a lot. the
visitors can also sing and
speak really get involved and feel the
science
that is being transported
here hermann is happy  singing springs
is the key word exactly but i'll take a
look after coupling
feedback to science there can't
tell you about a project what
we did
manager of an
artist karina batta who took care of the
mental illness of bipolar
disorders and is also involved
scientific  Researchers from different
disciplines have researched and created a
virtual reality environment
in which visitors can immerse
themselves, so they see then have the wii are glasses
on and then experience the
different episodes from completely
normal to
sky-high rejoicing I can fly to the
stars  i am omnipotent until
then in the padded cell, which is getting tighter and tighter
where i am all alone
and this work has led to a
lot of affected people
or
relatives of patients coming to us in the exhibition room
and they said now i understand
that  finally what is
going on now i have an idea of it i can feel
t for myself i am only
ver an outsider who has to react
to what is pouring in but a
so scientists psych
atrists who have worked with such peopl
have
ooked at it  so was
now I have a completely different access
z  u of these experiences are worlds of experience
and i believe that something like this happens and something like
this can succeed then it is
definitely also in the added value in
society in science again
exactly so you all would also
say that it is important to feel that it is so
cheap  perhaps as a
spectator, as a citizen, as an affected
operator or affected person,
not only because I myself also treat many
patients with bipolar
disorder, but because
these mental illnesses and
many mental phenomena in general are
so abstract that they are sometimes
so difficult to explain, which is what leads
yes, also to the fact that such an
illness suddenly becomes a big
taboo and if you
somehow make it tangible, you find the
right language for it and that
also includes an artistically
conveyed one, then that is worth a lot,
it just doesn’t matter  talking about
health and illness  It's taboo for drivers to talk about
things like
that, and even if you
're just discussing whether it's the language
or not, another language, but
then you get into a conversation, so that's
incredibly
important, even I would be interested to know if you have
any experiences
you have done with your students
and the learning material to what extent do
such topics also come into play
so the question is how are
you actually doing what do you
actually want to talk about because i heard a
bit that this
vision of the future they also have to come from
a conscience  fears
do arise, so if you somehow
imagine an oxygen babble, that
means yes, I'm quite rightly concerned
that at some point there will probably not
be enough oxygen on earth,
so I can just imagine
that there are also a lot of fears,
maybe that's also the topic  depression,
especially because of young people, is
perhaps also a taboo subject  to what extent
does something like that, the current state, the
feeling now also play a role, since in
principle images of the future are always a
very important tool or also
science fiction that actually show
the hopes and fears of the
present as a means of expressing that
and with the students you can
already tell  the fact that the topic of climate and
nature totally overwhelms you and that its
hopelessness is actually there,
that scared me so much, but it's
really a big topic in wersen too,
with different shoes I've been working
on from
educated middle-class cities or
really focal schools and it's
very similar to that  since the lack of
fear of the future is
clearly visible and
we are trying to create a space
like a tent spies where you can
also say critically yes
i find 3d printing exciting but only up to
that point and then it makes me more
afraid because  somehow it doesn't happen
that we also
g  discuss it socially critically
and how we do it we try
to promote
it but i also have to say it's
natural hear these really great
artefacts and futur ii around which the
exhibits have to be all really
great places and then when i
'm so sad at the same time because i
think about the schools where exactly such an
encounter has to take place, we have
classrooms from 50 years ago, so
we don't manage to bring
science to the table even more and make such experiences accessible to
healthy children,
money shouldn't play a role
Experiments are probably
not that popular either.
By the way, the photo still has to be free of charge,
so I know whether it will stay that way,
but that's for school
classes  where work together and
the problem is there
again when did the schools üb  in general,
a free space
outside of the transfer of knowledge where we
absolutely have to get away from it in order
to be able to go there, so
a school in particular now also needs a change
from pure transfer of knowledge to
knowledge experiences for one’s own i am a
researcher of things and that’s
what i teach and that’s why we need  completely
different formats also in the schools
and i think maybe also with
one more point on this topic that also
called scientists has been
very fact-oriented for many years very emotionlessly and
we are humans but we have
feelings and we need attractive people that
keeps us as  culture together
me there we absolutely have to get back to the point
where science has
also told us good stories he we
are also trusting because they
just build on knowledge that's a
point I'm missing right now and watching
how can you do that not only in
places like this  how to create here but really
until breakfast  stisch the
single mum in reinickendorf
zone and i think that there the school
at the end if we look where do we meet
the ex society schools are
very very important places and that is why
i would wish that when
we talk about science and universities
we also talk about
speaking more about the normal school we would also
say that it had been heard here about the knowledge
of women it would be good
if the laboratory if science
also opened up again so now not
the futur ii about itself only as an
exhibition site and as an experience sword
of science  yes yes what is
yes but that i really like that
citizen science projects are
open to school classes for students to
maybe get very direct contact to
an organ pressure or to a
biotechnologist the organ
pressure
might not just say a word about it but it
would be  of course super exciting because
you learn about this experience in a completely different way
and  i can do that now from the field
of economics
if you sit young people at the
table and i will take the
lateral thinker approach then i have to say to myself what
i have always said before there are
people who ask questions who are completely different
critical or super
visionary and you can go a long way from that and
i think there is great added value
if young people are also allowed to
ask such questions of science from time to time
.
Ms. art just wanted to say we have
a whole range of institutions that
do exactly that, i.e. with school
laboratories like this  when you see how
many classes go through it each year
, that's significant,
it's a bit like asking what
changes you really have to make in the programs there, too, in
order
to integrate what you now bring with you
, the work and how you can
broaden it  because it is important
for the many who are studying to be teachers
to see that it is integrated into a course of study and other  on the other hand
, not to continue doing that or to always
do it the way you were used to, so
from my point of view, another point is very
important, that it should be conveyed to schoolgirls at an early stage that
the
knowledge of science works,
that you are already struggling to get a correct
result, but it
actually is  something
can be taken for granted that there are many errors and
sometimes doubts and detours along the way,
so that in the end learning
during the pandemic has made it
clear that by no means is
the solid wisdom in the
universities, but
that striving for it is the best possible
and to develop quickly
but there is always an integration
process between making mistakes and becoming more
correct and that it is nothing bad and that is
why no fixes are
spread but it is part of the work of
science and if you learn that
very early on that we do i
think  a really more than one breast
has whom  n one is then not frightened that it
is actually a little
different than what one has learned and that has
will also listen very carefully to this transparency.
I am also frightened that I only
learned what it is to know in the age of 25 in a privileged master's course
know come and
make your mistakes we do
that switch to this this is not a
status quo can actually exist
somehow and or since we are all hobby
biologists we finally know how
studies work
effectiveness of vaccinations is how high
we didn't know before either  although we
all got measles vaccinations,
probably
because something is moving, maybe there will be
another question that occurs to me right now:
how, of course,
science
journalism or journalism also played an important mediating role,
especially with the
young people we had  in the preliminary
talk they had said again they
s  panning you actually or maybe
also remarkable you found that there
are not that many good
knowledge transfer formats for young
people, especially in the corona
period that explain it really well
there was just one
thing and not much more what would
you wish for there somehow  which
channels where there might be
more happening so I mentioned
that I was shocking that we had to learn our
knowledge about the pandemic on youtube
videos, so to speak,
then just didn’t hear the podcast from a
boston exactly but so many
have made up their minds about it  drawn and
yes, i don't think it's in front of
less than 20 or 80 fans, but it's difficult because
i'm saying i don't want
to bring all young people now
to always consume tik tok just
because it's a good channel to
reach them and stuff like that  snail science
and again the stretcher heated under
three seconds somehow so very
quickly something stay  t depend on it and
that's much more important how we create learning formats in
schools or with extracurricular
learning formats where
dynamic don't know that an end
if somehow the eye
clinic finally works has such
topics that you might talk about it
again right away but if they are
spoken
thought at some moment exactly such topics that
have to happen in class
and i can always read the geography
book from 30 years ago just because
we can't afford anything else
at the moment i have the feeling it happens in
many places  so what that is, so to speak,
with many teachers
the will is there exactly for china with the
many then have the tools to bring that into
the lesson because they
hardly have time for new
lesson designs it’s all stressful pressure and they
aren’t either  always so much that maybe
new sources are concerned and then to
package them interactively  s format which also makes the
lessons seem
lively and you are very much on your
own yes right here there is a
question we also have a microphone so that the viewers can
also hear the live stream
when exactly you can
also ask questions here we also ask about
you can still chat or
ask
questions via twitter exactly how peace is my
name i am from the eu and charité
this whole topic what you say now
so bring science to the
population this interaction there will be
quite a lot  actually
more the question what actually happened to the
citizen science project
because there are also citizens on there
students should also be active there
have certain projects and then
you will find out how difficult it is
to gain knowledge i know woman
art especially  said and what is now said in
my life i today will be said
differently tomorrow so this game
of verse  ugly and wrong and
i don’t have any of that yet now anyone
else would have asked the next question
here at the natural history museum are
there are quite a lot of citizen
science projects also located
ultimately maybe i’ll
pass the question on to them too so maybe more needs to be
done  get their own place at
the universities so
the female scientists also have to be better equipped for the
citizen science project
if you
ask the female scientists now it is often the question or the answer what else should
i do exactly and
is the mobile phone
exactly that to me  shirt closer than
pants so because if you now
allow this flippant expression to the extent that you actually get
a secure position in the
science system because of your
scientific achievements
and your overall qualifications and not
because there have been a lot of well-done citizen
science projects  can
te change that theoretically, yes, i think that
this is also a
strand that will develop for the future, but
at the moment it's not like it
's an add-on
and it's great that so many people
like to do it  if you want
to do that, you also need to be
offered service how do i do it,
what needs to be taken into account
and who takes over the
preparation and learning from me to
really be accompanied to the extent
that it then succeeds and
not everyone does it again  reinventing the wheel
it's our turn so that also a small
note there is also the white paper
citizen science for this this enemy
strategy of the federal government by
8.30 p.m  yes, and
it's also because that's becoming
more established at the universities, of course
, and just like us, that's what's happening
now  in fact, the lions within the framework of
their excellence strategy is
not directly comparable with citizen
science projects here in-house because
observations of nature, for example,
are queried with a very broad audience and then the
results are often used in the
sense  one of a descriptive
cooperation, so you can find birds,
nightingales and so on, but when it
comes to biodiversity research, that
’s a big point, so
the researchers are really dependent on the
help of the citizens, so to speak,
and that’s of course especially for
the youngest and for
students in a really great
start too at the beginning what we now
want to do within the framework of the airlines is,
if you like, selective
citizen science because more geared towards
that,
i know from certain circles i know what the ngo found it
started to become business
enterprises and other stakeholders  rn in society should
always be won from these groups with
actors for
the development of new
research questions and it is
currently important that we
allow the freedom to deal
with them so that the funding
actually comes from the reduction or
free semesters
and the support  in the area of
e at the moment our m
in action is so that there is no fixed
program but you can do wh
tever you want it would have to be related to th
big issues that
erlin wants to do here, so so
ial cohesion holds logo and then
he other issues but  othe
you can think about
what you like and will of
course also start from your own
scientific expertise
from 1 was that it is precisely
to get these resources from the
university to do projects that do
not fit into the impact factor
streamline that is  really a big
problem we  with this how
do i find artist-scientist
pairings, we always started a lot on the
part of the artists
and had now advertised in the last year it
was said that
scientific institutions apply
to us for such a cooperation and we
will then help you find a suitable
artist  and
we wanted the commitment from the
institute as well and a bit of soy you
have a bit of money for it so that
the artists can be brought to the laboratory salt of
course also stimulates science itself
and that’s especially difficult at the
popular universities in
Germany  to get money for things like
that that are not directly related to science
,
so we really found out that
this is actually not possible, so
anyway it is a commitment from the
scientists who say
i take my free time to deal with the
artists but  then
also k  getting a resource
is also a problem and i
think we should work on that
as an example, janne said fung,
however, it's his kind of project
that works together with the biotechnologists of the tu
ja, they just
mess up research with artists
together exactly there are such
individual possibilities, especially
at these
non-university
research institutions like
helmholtz leibnitz max planck they can
therefore have an institute basis that makes the
funds available for but just the
classical
[music]
university professor
seems to be there so i’m there too in
this one  the science system isn't that good
but if you talk to them
it's probably difficult
to somehow provide even minimal funds
, so that's why we
actually have real money for it and
we also have a service
facility
in which he once worked with the  knowledge
exchange  office who help there somehow
but you still need the time
you need the good idea and
i think you have to learn step by step
how to actually change your own
scientific thinking
on the one hand it doesn’t get wrong because
he said earlier it’s always a
conversation  with each other, where does it go
wrong and how much do you
actually dare to say in a
scientific world that has been familiar for so long, yes,
i'll do it and i don't look
straight away to see if my colleagues think it's good
, but i get something
back from it that i do  otherwise would never have found out
so that my research suddenly
got an infection that
in turn motivates the students
to stay with me and to take part,
for example, we held
an open humor festival on the north campus
and experimented with a
pilot project in the city's arboretum
or the
scientist of the
humboldt university and there  was it
really great what you
actually find on such a green space and
what can
then be
put together in the knowledge that you have brought with you and how you can
actually manage your green space differently as a university
you gave a very
small
example for example i just did
Jan Trockenrasen reported about that,
but the long wall was
also very exciting, yes, to the pencil, yes, but I also wanted to be important when you look at it,
where do the students
and the staff go, that is, the
niece professorship that you cannot hold at the
university
it's important for the doctoral students that
they also see other possibilities and that they
have a connection to society
and I think it's a very
good step to say yes, we are
diverse at the university and also
allow other CVs to
be a good example  exactly exactly
i have to think about it all the time
the fact that
we can link up with citizen science is great, based in jersey
so the idea of a throne only from 18 onwar
s I won’t tell you my normal found
tion or something like a startup but not m
own company a student company or ev
n as a doctoral student I someh
w found something and  linking the two
so this knowledge and then it was also to
act i have important points i
didn't want to do it again right here
there are more questions i'll ask a
quick question back there arthur there are questions about twitter
somehow that exactly maybe
let them die first  just ask a
question i can pass on because
asked about the role of the media for the
trusting exchange at eye level
whether they strengthen or weaken
and strengthen or weaken exactly the
media itself i.e. what role
media plays there what i just mentioned a
bit  had exactly so
would you perhaps also want more what
would you perhaps wish for
more we  some formats of science communication
in the media
in different media are
necessary so i was very
happy that the ard and zdf would now have made
krone films for students and
therefore for the school
so i find it a very important
point that there are good documentaries
there are and the public broadcasters
have really
great offers with quax, for example with the
short instagram videos, also in exactly
so i realize that it is
very, very difficult for journalists to
actually be allowed to represent science broadly, i.e. the topic of science
i would like for us to have a
bit
more diversity again so that
it is more important in the editorial departments and
if you look at it
internationally and if
you look at the newspapers in india
there are actually headlines there that
deal with
scientific topics  because because there the that
striving for the future is also
directly connected to it by many young people
and it is simply not present
enough here at the moment
, so we always
try to find media partnerships with our formats
and have, for example, for the
development of ideas for the theater of the
anthropocene from android
android  os together had really great
support from the time, who accompanied
the 2 very critically,
but at least it was reported, so
that making it known is very, very
important because it
stabilizes the fact that we want to be a
knowledge society and that
also with the subordination that
the  political topic
science policy the importance that
is that is also being widely
communicated now but i find a very
interesting example for that the
theater of the centro 10
goes into other rooms in a theater rooms so in
the volksbühne for example oedipus and
i have them  also
report about it  htet, for example, was radio one
and of course that's not so easy to
convey in advance, but we know
scientists like antje boetius,
the director of
the alfred-wegener-institute, who can
tell really great stories, who can tell lively
science and i
would just about it  to find new narrative forms
really dare to go on stage
as an oracle in
the volksbühne and play there and i
not only find that courageous but i also think that it
is a good
way to make science accessible jan is
sender radioeins from rbb clear reports
we then also about it so that
’s natural for us it would be nice so
i think he played it too, an
exchange between the media and female
scientists is somehow very
important or even finding a common
language although i also think
that female scientists are of course
not trained for this and  per
se there are somehow all the time
so communicate a  lso to study this on a
stage of the register because
it's just the very few alone it
will help that you somehow have
a little more space in the daily news
for science topics so
well before corona science was actually only ever in
for the Nobel Prizes
the main news but I have no
idea 20 minutes for
soccer results that everyone who was interested in you had already seen in the
sports studio
so you could
really bring science a
bit more to the general
public right
here there was another question there was
that one  lady hello i'm back to bed is
back and i'm currently writing my
master's thesis on climate buildings or
tables and i also lead a
project workshop at the tu berlin and
we're actually trying to bring together the
various projects in the area of
nability and w
th the students different proje
ts, i.e. external ones  projects too
well, with the fancy
research institutes, not only from the tu
and not only from the campus, but with
bringing together different is killing and with the punching to do projects like
that and
so that is for us, for me,
that was great, for example, difficult,
just like that  we give so much
time and for example we
do projects in this place and we present
our university but sometimes it is
super difficult to get the funding
and
so for example at the university i have
maybe 567 e-mails admitting so fashion exactly
the funding sites but for example  at
the helmholtz they give, for example, in
the institutes this funding
and so different so they have this
special funding program but i think that needs to be more about
this thing so wii version
to achieve this sustainable goal
and we as students the several
projects will then be important  bring to the
university and then could express these ideas so such a platform therefore  n well
i might find a bit more here
at the universities, for example this
alliance i think is so great but i
don't know if you can really get the
ideas so you can
get the funding from there and
that was a difficult thing for us
because  we also invite fashion experts
to these lastingly ice-breaking
professors and that's
exactly what this bridge is sometimes
difficult and my tailor-made work is also i
've otherwise
found the opportunity to present the other or
anja and that was under berlin's path
and that's exactly why this branch of
science he  it was also very so
i noticed that day when i can
talk to people about my project
and my thoughts on the
climate protection goals my
research topics and then it is important
so there is also feedback from the population
and it is very important
is if so i
noticed that day that's a bit this if we
this  events can do more then
i think that would be how can i do it
again so that will then that
comes different
possibilities of this project
continue will not only be so
exactly that is not only stays with you
but that the exchange takes place
maybe i would ask the question  there
is now a sustainability office
at humboldt university and
now i was just
wondering to what extent maybe that
even though there is an alliance
between the different big
universities in berlin then this
competition is getting in the way a bit
so the hu did a sustainability job, for example,
where i
could imagine that where it is
also about the sustainability strategy of
the who itself what it comes from the
students themselves now i hear
from another university in berlin
it is apparently not the case  easy to
establish that is maybe even
then  its competition
among the universities or what people are
thinking again
no i don’t
think so i would say a year and a half ago i
had a very intensive discussion
with the various groups that deal
with sustainability and
sustainability goals that came from
all the universities they are
particularly active  also
student groups
on the one hand at the free university and
on the one hand at the humboldt university i do
n’t know exactly what it looks like at the
technical university so
i would really recommend
getting in touch with the relevant groups via humboldts 17 or via the portals of the free university
because, for example, those with
us have also developed their own degree in ecology
and we have now taken
the first steps to prepare
sustainable construction
measures for our own university
via
climate managers
and then to
initiate them so far they will have money for
it  about the berlin university
alliance you have to say something to mr rösler so
that what you are asking is there but
i don't know exactly right now
from the hip
more precisely maybe you will accept it
because sustainability is now an
example we had it  there
were also very similar students at a university
we wanted to convey this topic to the outside world
we just didn’t
become a researcher so stayed at the university
in science research and told me
we want
science communication and then hear
gmbh sis from the university and then
we’re missing the pots  we are
not a limited company we are not really in an association we are but we have one thing in
common we are only allowed to
take from donations only from foundation funds
so if we are also talking about
science and society and
politics here why is
n’t there politics here too, for example
only from you uni pot
instrument with scholarships with wise
non
scholar in acton
they just communicate for a year, come up with
things and are allowed to get a good
salary then a certain budget
so that we
somehow create new instruments politically
always discuss the unconditional basic income
or even then the green thing
come down for scientists in action the
amas  a few years directly after
unicef there were so many young peopl
who have great bachelor’s or maste
’s theses and would like to make
omething out of it, so why aren’t there funds
to enable it to be appreciated because i know
bout them the crown time was quite
violently as a non-profit
organization you have all these
pots that were then given by the
government don't assume we are
nice everywhere by winning but
they still exist but you
are looking for sponsors or
foundations that yes so we always need
exactly mr  rösler from the objective
knowledge exchange viell  maybe you can
give another tip to the lady,
yes, she's very welcome, so Mrs. art, he
already said, is the german exchange office,
the berliner style 1, this
contact point will be the interface
for these projects at the interface between
science and society, and
especially for your case  so that you have finished
a scientific project, so to speak
, and now want to do
scientific communicative exchange
formats for it that is exactly
why we will offer money that
is not yet available for the top you can
not apply now, but if
everything goes well we can start the next one from the beginning
year then supporting student
scientists from the four
partner universities with such
projects
but it is still a good tip
to contact the other universities
because there are already really great
student projects
there but i have a question here
still looked closely at the lady before
Thank you very much for the lengthy discussion
I wanted to pick up on
the decoupling between science
and politics and also the word mpeg, which is
also a lot
like because your experience is, so
to speak, all these great results that
arise when science and
society work together  to
really pass that on to political
decision-
makers who then really lead to a change,
so to speak, which i, as a citizen of berlin,
for example, also feel, so how
do you go to the municipalities color to the
administration how do you do that, so
that i don’t have a bit of an
understanding for  how does that happen
maybe also a question for
aristocrats so that's a very important
question and we have to fight for this exchange and for
this transfer of knowledge, especially in
politics that
is not so self-evident and i
can
report from our experience that eurobahn is  i
so i had to when we dam  When it
started, it wasn't
that politicians were
waiting for it because it was perhaps
not so
well known and expected that
this kind of path would be taken, but we
have to open doors as research and
somehow also as society
into politics to get
our message there and
so i don't want to talk too much
about it but for example
we started a few years ago
the charter a charter of the eurobahn
sticks we wrote that in
an exchange with
fellow citizens of berlin
we have drawn up these new charter
points with various groups of actors new areas
of urban life where this where
this interdisciplinary and transdisciplinary
thinking together
can deliver meaningful results such as public
spaces such as culture in the city so
we have
written and summarized something on these points and
this project was one would now
expect it's also about
health primarily after how can you
create a healthy city so
yes you would expect for that then you had to
start by
pressing buttons with the health administration
in this city, so to speak, and first of all we
got the support from the
senate administration for culture and europe well
where i wouldn't
have expected it to come from and well it's
these paths are still beaten paths and
should be widened and i
think we have to fight for that too
and that's right they have
a long time for it  fought secure to get
exactly that what would
you say so now this content has been
added we have the
same problems when it is
actually about rolling out and getting
the interest of
larger funding institutions so
since we cooperate closely with antje
boetius it is up to us now
for example not successful for this
theater project where nature is like that  quasi
speaks and and also questioned and
questioned why certain things in
the present of nature is the way
it is today we have written many
applications but nothing successful
so you have to clearly admit that so that
at the moment the financial
resources of the  airlines are available for this
and that is otherwise a
hard bread the entire
cultural area has come very strongly in the
last few years to compensate for
corona
failures
there is currently no
really well integrated case in the
scientific community so that on a
very abstract level in the
federal ministry  for research and
technology with the viscom viscom
factory, on a very abstract
level, all the actors there who were of rank and
name bustled about, but
that has not yet led to a
concrete definition for the system, so
it is to be expected that this will now happen in
the next  time happens but at the moment
it's always a until  put your
hand in your mouth
so then thanks for the question who is very
important right here is now yes that
noticed the final gong right here
right here in front because you are
already at the end I deserve a very short look
a very small look
again maybe catch  we with you at the
beginning of may, of course, it was now
also about money, about establishing yourself
somehow in politics in
society, but what would you wish for
from your perspective from the
non-profit organization of the
schering foundation what more needs to
happen for a better one  exchange
between science and, in this case,
art and culture, maybe you can also
get
something right now,
so it was just money, i
just said
that you have the simple answer, but
maybe it's also
openness and the courage to take other
paths  to go and to go into the insecurity
so that's also what if
you w  conveyed by science it is
also the courage to face
uncertainty first and
strive for something and i think we need
that a bit more in
society too very nice
woman like how is it with you what what
are the next projects up  who
are perhaps also now so
perspective from a future
farmer exactly from the institute future
farmer what are you looking forward to
especially now maybe in the
near future so to
be honest which exchange students are we going to right now and
then we don’t even know if it’s
like that  continues as before because we
really have money problems and
that's why i think it's very
important to talk about it because i know so
many non-profit educational
actors social innovations who where burnout is a
real issue stress because this
constant asking for money this
order is also not cool
about it  there is a lot of bureaucracy,
so I would just  oh
wish that this goes away or is
reduced and above all have a contact person
so
i have to say i
don't even know where i should
classify myself i'm no longer in
science but i do something with
science i'm not a
commercial company on the market  company i
'm not fully involved in
non-profit either so where do i
actually belong it's just the
process
and nothing for that was
really important to have a contact person
from politics maybe also or in
berlin where initiatives like
us too  social entrepreneur ships can turn to
somehow exactly yes
we yes then definitely wish you
that maybe through
today's conversation that maybe
a few new
networks will somehow arise exactly
probably it's better that
somehow
somehow together with other initiatives  do yes the money
so i'm already felling that i
didn't know about you before and i
think it's a really great great project
future farmer exactly what a very
important question when can you
try out this app from the
national city so we hope that you'll
be in the download area at the beginning of 20 22 then he
understands  getting the app
store is of course
free of charge how are you currently developing
together with the king's college in
london and
and how is that so new ways
citizen science are brings with it a wealth
of questions, for example data protection law
these are new questions the same as the the
data protection officers in our universities, for
example, don’t always have everyone
ready as an answer
and that’s why such steps are such
steps only when you are the first
and as a pioneer pioneering work
somehow makes it difficult and takes a long time
but i hope that we are ready at the beginning of
22  and that
berliners will also make plenty of
use of it
[music]
then join in too  make and be introduced yourself
in German the
project is called in English about the emotional city of
morgan city and it will start soon
yes and you can also include a few
ideas from the future building shops
the oxygen babbel or
something like
that exactly the organic farmer  very strongly
linked to hear by location
maybe you can still
connect exactly
thanks a lot maybe the
final question woman art exactly what
do you want now
for further scientific exchange
i
wish that this
important this important area of
dge exchange actually flourishes  and
thrives wonderfully great conclusion
nothing more to add thank you very much
for listening to the live stream and
also here in the boardroom of the natural history museum
thank you for this exciting discussion to
Mrs. Kunst to math adli and aline and
katja well thank you for the networking
too and on Sunday wishes you still in the
he goes on  at the moment i
would like to have a little daughter for
you then it is about exactly climate research and
the
climate conference also a very
important topic thank you for your commitment thank you very much
[applause]